hey guys welcome to my podcast
congratulations
crazy crazy
crazy
[Music]
ah you know guys hi first of all and
second of all
uh i want to thank you for all the
patreon members that
are on my patreon really really
appreciate you guys
patreon.com crystalia uh and
uh you know it's awesome to have you
guys with us on the discord chatting
uh whether you're on the tier for six
dollars or you're on the
the greater tier um i appreciate you
showing support for the show uh if
you're not on patreon
we still freaking absolutely love you
dude
if you're listening from youtube if
you're listening from you know whatever
it is spotify or
uh uh apple uh what is it [ __ ]
podcast then we appreciate you there too
we've got a favor to ask
just take a minute to just
absolutely [ __ ] obliterate that like
button
to just come [ __ ] to [ __ ]
absolutely just [ __ ] it up that with
that ak-47
and just just blam blam blam on that
[ __ ]
on that uh subscription button
and then take a [ __ ] cannon into the
mortar
and then light it up and then kneel down
and hold your ears right over that
[ __ ] bell notification
while then while the mortar [ __ ]
but yeah dude just storm the [ __ ]
like button
because here's the thing man it helps us
it helps the video get traction
if you comment make sure to make friends
in those comments
and uh and and um talk to each other you
know
let's get that [ __ ] algorithm going
it really helps man
if you're a baby this is what you uh
this is your call to arms
you know how does this cult grow if his
cult doesn't grow
um how's this called grow if this cult
can't grow
um so yeah dude thank you thank you
thank you and um just so you know that
it really helps i'm in the [ __ ] life
rips
gear check this out i also got the
shorts on
because life stays ripping and you know
that
uh everyone got their [ __ ] [ __ ] and
uh
they're wearing it and posted about it
and we just see how life keeps ripping
for everybody but i will tell you this
uh we it was a limited edition
and it did so well people are just
[ __ ] clamoring for it back that we
absolutely restocked it so go out and
get that [ __ ] get this [ __ ] right
here
show everybody that life rips uh go live
at crystalia.com
and don't know why i said live but you
just go to chrisley.com and get that and
you can also
we have more we have new merch the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that i've been waiting for
be more memorable these [ __ ]
are memorable for the wrong reasons
be more member you know what some of a
lot of these [ __ ] are not
memorable at all
but be more memorable and sport these
[ __ ] dope hoodies
and uh what do we got hoodies and i
don't know what we got for sale but
we're putting it up all up on here
and it's just a beautiful design just
rocking that [ __ ] across your chest
telling these [ __ ] to be more
memorable
and god forbid if you're wearing one of
those hoodies and somebody comes up and
says hey what's going on hey what's
up what's up hey oh yeah oh hey how you
doing [ __ ] kathy oh yeah what oh you
don't remember me huh
and kathy's got on that hoodie that says
be more memorable you just point to that
[ __ ] and say it ain't my fault
i don't know who you are but that's the
positive [ __ ] to spread this year
be more memorable dude
you know we all start as little ones and
we grow up and we just get used to the
hustle and bustle of life
but you gotta remember why you're in it
dude you gotta remember why you're in it
and if you don't remember why you're in
it then why the [ __ ] is anyone else
gonna remember
you you understand so this [ __ ] means
something to me
got the good coffee
i made it myself this time i was like
hey babe do you think you can uh
she was already sat down and i was like
ah
which one is it she's like the pike's
place and i was like all right cool
and we did it dude working as a team
me getting the coffee and her just
sitting there at that moment that was
what it was but working as a team for
the most part she was sitting there and
i was getting the coffee but for the
most part
now we're just chilling we're doing the
podcast we're just chilling dude and
that's the way it should be
absolutely chillville just absolutely
chillville
population population three because i
even get rid of is in here but i'll tell
you who's not here
one fire now how did he get the name one
fire because
on fire the reason why he's not here
is because he is at a very important
i don't even know what the [ __ ] joke
to make honestly he's just not here
he's in vegas dude he's in [ __ ] vegas
with his girl
just taken off i didn't know till
yesterday
he was like oh you know what we have a
reservation at [ __ ] whatever the hell
it is
and i was like where's that and he said
vegas i said you're in vegas and he said
[ __ ]
he's staying in the bellagio with
rosales fire
his dude it's so [ __ ] annoying dude i
didn't know it was
the guy's and i see he said i said
you're in vegas he said yeah he said
sorry i'll be at dinner i can't be there
to record and i said
worst employee ever and he sent me three
shrimp emojis
these are the [ __ ] i'm dealing
with dude
so chillville population three dude we
don't need him
[Music]
little mystery on who he is still even
um
yeah dude we're chilling uh we're
having a good time we're flying by the
seat of our pants we're firing on all
syllables
and um dude
what happened let's see what happened
this week well i'll tell you what
happened this week and it was beautiful
man
well first of all calvin walks by the
back uh calvin's my son if you're not
long time
well if you're not a long time listener
if you're not a person that heard me
talk about my son already
if you don't if you're not if you have
heard me like people i'll say firing all
syllables and people be like fire enough
syllables are you sure bro and i'm like
oh hi
you're new here um
but yeah but calvin walked by
uh he does this thing now where he walks
by the
pool and he says poo poo poo poo poo poo
and it's so cute and then he runs up to
the window
like and and puts his hands up on the
window and he's like poo
poo poo poo just the fact that i know
that what that is does that give me
access to it
and i'm just like no you know what we
can't i don't know if we can
pool pool pool and so i brought him in
once
and then we came back he took a nap then
he woke up and he just goes
he opened his eyes he'd go and he says
poor pool and i'm like all right
all right going again [ __ ] it we have a
good day it was like a saturday so i
take him in the pool for a while bring
him back
uh and then he walks by the thing again
pool pool
and i'm like not this time man you don't
nobody goes in the pool three three
three times in one [ __ ] day
you know unless you're a swim instructor
like that's insane
and then i'm like not three times and
he's like poo poo poo poo poo
and i'm like no no and he just slid down
the glass like he was watching his
[ __ ] mom and dad being taken away in
auschwitz
just starts crying and i'm like
i had no good reason to except for
standing by my no
i had no good reason and not bring him
in i'm like all right dude you better
grow up to be a [ __ ] swim instructor
that makes
just bank cause i don't think anybody
really wishes for their kid to grow up
to become a swim instructor no offense
to
swim instructors but if you do i hope
you create some sort of new way to swim
and make [ __ ]
biddly bit angk off that um
this way you [ __ ] get no deadlies um
yeah dude uh and so i'm like all right
i'll bring him in for the third time
pull as i'm bringing i'm like i get it
dude chill and we bring him in
for the third time the next day
i had to go to the [ __ ] beach now i
don't know if you know
much about me
but your boy doesn't like
sand anywhere
the sand should be
at the beach it's how i feel
i'm not shying away from it okay
they say speak your truth try not to lie
when it comes to the beach i wanna be
indoors
okay my [ __ ] friend
invited me and also sent a separate text
to wifey
so i couldn't exactly nip it in the bud
if you know what i mean
your boy is gonna have to get
sand in his toes because his
bud went behind his back
okay now he's talked about you're
probably like well chris why didn't you
just
i have told him in the past
not to text wifey
behind my back all right
but he was like [ __ ] it you're a new man
now it's
telling me it's part of my [ __ ] i gotta
learn to be a real person
so i take and you and he's like and you
can't get mad at me anymore
the dude double crossed me
those that have anger issues went
behind my back
texted you know so
so now i'm sitting there and i'm like
and and i
i hear my [ __ ] go and i see the text and
then i hear from the other room
and i go no and then i hear
ooh and i'm like
stab me in the front that's a stab you
in the front move
that's not oh what do you do
oh no that's a hey chris come here have
a conversation what's up guys hey what's
going
on but before you realize it's going
down south it's upsy daisy in your
plexus
so i've got a [ __ ] handle sticking
out of my plexus
because i hear [ __ ] ding from the
other room and then
oh that's as a man in a relationship
the lat the only thing worse than
hearing from the other room
ding ooh is
ding oh no
but guess who went oh no after that
you boy
so it goes
oh no so now i got to go to the [ __ ]
beach
she says oh you want to go to the beach
and i and i say i don't want to but i'm
learning to
you know do the things for the family
and yes
i will go to the beach uh and i'm going
to try and have as much fun
as possible and i will and
so we get we
i we showed up
and it was like there's just people in
like vans with like wetsuits
on halfway and just dirty as [ __ ]
and they look like they would have 30
000 followers on instagram and that's
the dude
you know and just blonde guys just
yucking it up that's the thing about the
beach is that there's no shortage of
blonde dudes
where the [ __ ] are they out they just
stay at the beach it must be because i
see
dudes out the ratio is way different
when you're at the beach
that guy's at the beach all the time
that's a beach ass living
and there were like vans and [ __ ] and of
course the crazy people
and of course my girls doing the girl
thing like would it be
these are you know it'd be it's such a
slow pit and i'm just like don't get any
[ __ ] thoughts
you were there for me and you'll always
be there for me
and i love you to death but don't we're
not
we're not moving we're not moving the
beach i love you
i love you like my arms but we're not
moving to the beach
okay um and we got another friend with
us and calvin's there just
like i've never been this far west
and our other friend is like i love the
beach and so we're getting there and
your boy's getting sand in between his
toes
you park so far away you never park near
where you're gonna be
my buddy's like hey we're at the beach
where
i said something like santa monica i'm
like narrow it down
he's like tower 27. drop a pit
so we get there and it's always like you
think it's easy but looking for somebody
at the beach
is like looking for a nickel at the
beach
it's so hard dude you're like they're
just people none of them look like my
friend
there's nine people out here and i've
looked at all nine
but i try to feel the ground and we're
walking and it's way harder to walk on
sand than it is on [ __ ] regular
ground so why would anybody go to the
beach
and calvin has already seen sand that's
the thing he's looking down at saying
like i remember
you from the sandbox because we have a
sandbox
and um
and we get to the spot we finally see
him because my buddy's throwing a
football
like he's in the on the 49ers and [ __ ]
and he's just him everyone has that
buddy that thinks on the 49ers but
really he's just him
and um and so we get there and we plop
down
and calvin before he's just looking at
the sand he looks up and he sees this
big vast body of water
and he looks at the water and he's got
that really focused
face that i get sometimes when i'm
focusing on something
and he's looking at it and he looks at
me and looks back at the water
and he looks back at me and it looks
like he's thinking
i never is this the end of the world
what happens if you go out there i never
seen anything like that
usually wherever i step it's just more
places to step
but this looks like and then he says
says it to me he looks at me one time
points out to the water and says
and i just [ __ ] melted
and i said yeah it is the pool
it's the big pool
and we sat down and
we uh played in the sand
he cried a little bit because there were
about 20 people there uh of our friends
and then um he got used to it we got him
an ice cream
uh he ate the batman ice cream and the
[ __ ] mouth was so blue he kept on
trying to give it to me dropped it in
the sand and then mom tried to
take the sand off and he was crying
because he was like but
now in my hands so i can put in my mouth
and there's another step involved
me taking that from you so let's have
let's shorten that step
and um we gave it back to him and he ate
it
hit like [ __ ] that day but i will tell
you this dude i had a
you know one time when i was 21 i was
with my
roommate's parents and his
and my roommate's mom said boy isn't
that wonderful and i said wonderful huh
and she said yeah
and i said nobody really says that huh
and she said what do you mean and i said
like how come you just don't say good or
even great you know but wonderful
and she laughed and ever since then any
time
i think about using the word wonderful i
stopped myself
because i said that and i didn't want to
be
i didn't want to go back on my word or i
didn't want to
this is the way my head works i mean i'm
41 now and this was 21 years ago
and i think i've probably said the word
wonderful only in
either jest or explaining how somebody
else said the word wonderful
in the last 20 years and i'm not
bullshitting
so i'mma tell you right now that that
day on that beach
with my family was wonderful
it really was and um
it was just cool man i even threw the
football a little bit
hey boy's got an arm man i mean i i do i
have an arm i
toss him out like steve young and i you
know i don't do just like him but is
a little bit reminiscent of him and and
when i when i toss it out
you know i'm not gonna lie it hurts and
every time i do it which i did it about
four or five times i tossed it out
i thought maybe i heard my rotator cuff
and i well in fact i did hurt my rotator
cuff but i thought that i was going to
be
doing actual damage to my rotator cuff
and i said you know what
i had that conversation every 41 year
old man has when he hurts himself a
little bit
when hurts himself a little bit i guess
i'll find out tomorrow if it's serious
or not when i wake up
you know what i mean well if it hurts
tomorrow when i wake up
i guess i'll just be [ __ ] in that area
for the rest of my life
because that's it once you're 40 or 36
37 or i guess if you're an athlete or no
if you're an athlete before that but
like
if you're somebody who's got a good body
a well-working body maybe you can make
it to like 43
but you wake up and your shit's in pain
that area of your body's done
it's just done dude it was like how
[ __ ] uh it's like it's like
it's like john favreau after iron man 2
he's just like i did i did it already
i'm not doing the third one
um so yeah i uh that's your body
john john that's when you get pain in
your body at 40 that's john favreau
saying and that's a picture wrap
noah knowing damn well he's not
coming back for the third one and that's
a picture wrap for iron man 2. thank you
mickey rourke
thank you uh [ __ ] the guy with
three named robert downey jr that chris
can't think of because he probably's got
a tumor somewhere in his head
uh and thank you whoever the female was
that we hired
that oh pepper potts who played that
gwyneth paltrow
thank you and that's a picture wrap
that's him doing that in your knee when
you do a crossover
at 39 years old at a [ __ ] park in
burbank when you're
playing basketball with the fellas you
ain't on the nets
you're not even on a team at the y um
so yeah i um i had a great day with uh
with the family and now and now he just
loves the pool now even little water we
we got him a pool table like a table
with not a pool table a table
they put water in it it's got like a
slide in it and [ __ ] i'll take a picture
i'll put it right here but
um and he uh
and he just looks at it and he's just
like
it's cute um yeah
so you know when i did see iron man dude
i you know i have ocd
and [ __ ] and it's really really some
days it's really debilitating
other days it's at bay but um
i do i don't i hate when people hand
[ __ ] to me like i have a [ __ ] weird
thing i i don't even
whenever i talk about my ocd i feel like
somebody talking like
about their ocd that doesn't really have
ocd because
people have like made it cute to be like
ocd
i don't like to take too many steps or
whatever the [ __ ]
oh i can't go to the grocery store on
tuesday
i was like you don't get it if i do it i
think i'm gonna die in a plane wreck
and i don't just think that i know that
and i don't just know it
i know it for five days and um
[Music]
and so i uh have a thing you know i've
tried to
do behavioral uh cognitive behavioral
therapy and uh
obviously i'm on meds but uh i have this
thing where people
hand me stuff i'd rather them just lay
it down it [ __ ] bugs it really bugs
me it gets to me
and um when i watch iron man iron man's
like
people hand him he's like i don't like
when people hand me stuff to put it down
and i'm just like oh [ __ ] dude
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
he's like he's like they're making him
am i marginalized are we
just shooting fire out of my hands and
my boosters
with just some shorts on and
a shirt that's too long
it's shorts and i fall down and hurt my
neck and john favre yells cut in his
neck that's a picture wrap
thank you crystalia you are not iron man
you're 40 and it hurts
how did i do that you just sound
underwater when you do it
[Music]
i'm good dude [ __ ] npr
and [ __ ] these other podcasts man
i love some of them you know some of
them are good like that what's the one
crime junkies that one's good they got
like mcdonald's ads on their [ __ ]
they're so big they're just like have
you ever had a big mac try a big mac and
you're just like
jesus they're just making [ __ ]
bigs um
so i'm training myself to want to do
stuff like go to the beach and yeah i'm
training myself like a [ __ ] dolphin
one time uh i was at a bar with my other
buddy who looks just like tom cruise
unbelievable and uh
except he was like six feet and uh i
haven't talked to him in a long long
time but there was a girl that sat down
at our table
all the girls liked him
and uh she was talking to us
and he said so what do you do that's how
he talked so what do you do
for like a living to her he really did
sound like that
and she said i'm a trainer and i said
oh for what dolphins and she and she
just
goes like this and looks at me and she
says
literally she said see you just did like
one of
the things that like i don't like
and i was just like i
it's one thing to be like that wasn't
funny like i would have taken that on
the chin
and been like all right i won't do jokes
to you
and i i kind of like know how funny that
was like
it's just fine funny it's not like i'm
gonna win any awards for it
i probably wouldn't even write it in a
script but like
and even if i was gonna say it as an
ad-lib in a script it would be because
the character's jerky you know
like but she said see
you just like did one of those things
that i don't like
it's what she said and i never forgot it
and uh
and i said like what
a joke and she said
no yeah it's just like i don't know
that's it those are the people we deal
with in our lives
those are the people we deal with in our
lives
and there's nothing you can do about it
dude these are the people
in our lives
she's probably 50 now um
i don't know dude but whatever he didn't
like her either he was like ah
and oh that guy was so funny dude
i'm not gonna say his name but dude the
guy [ __ ] one time
so girls liked him he was also one of
those canadian dudes
that like just is like there's a
difference between
uh the way americans are and canadians
are when it comes to
interacting with the opposite sex like
uh canadians are just like
what's every girl gonna like me who
cares you know
just say hi and americans are like
uh let's all go over over there and get
uh and get too close you know
let's all get too close so
uh she doesn't understand what's
happening and then one of us will just
be like
hey what's up with your dress really
loud
and um and so he would just like say hi
to everybody and he would like start
with like you know you're really
gorgeous you have great eyes and i'm
just like you're not gonna
oh just lead with the thing about how
what's up with her dress
and there's only two of us should we get
more guys
and um but he would do that and there
was this one girl playing the violin
or the guitar i don't remember because
those instruments are the same to me
what am i [ __ ] coldplay and um
who am i cisco
[Music]
um that's opera i'm an opera singer and
so he
um so he [ __ ]
we went to the thing we went to uh we
went to the we were on third street
promenade and there was a
there was a a girl playing the violin or
guitar i don't remember
and he and he was like i'm gonna give
her some
dollar bills in the cup you know she was
like a whatever she had a license to do
the street performance
and he was like and i said okay and he
did it i saw him walk over and do it
and he was like hey it was in between
songs and he was like chatting her up in
the middle of the song i'm like
the song ends and then they're chat and
i'm like jeez he's gonna figure all
right i'll walk over there i don't wanna
i don't wanna stand near [ __ ] cl uh
what's the club monaco i'm i'm just
gonna
walk over we start talking and she says
oh hey what's up i say oh hey good job
my name's chris and he's just like yeah
cool we're talking and [ __ ]
and on the way back we were listening to
the backstreet boys and i remember
um we were talking about
her because she was really you know
she's like a good an attractive female
and he was like
you know um she was totally in into it
and i was like oh really and i was like
i don't [ __ ] know i mean i was 21
dude
i had no idea and uh and he was like
yeah and i said
how do you know and he said dude he said
ah because you could just tell by the
way she was talking to us or me or
whatever
i turned the music louder
i turned the music louder because it was
probably my first
uh dude how did he how did he say it i
i literally i told my brother afterwards
and we've laughed so
you could probably you could tell she
was into it because of the way she was
talking to us or me or whatever
oh that's what he said and i never
forgotten
[Laughter]
dude that is the [ __ ] man
man you look just like tom cruise people
will come up to him black dudes will
come up to him because black
if you look a little bit like tom cruise
and you're white
white people will be like that's not tom
cruise but black people will be like
hey when's mission possible six coming
out
the same for white people to black like
people are always like
like people was like that's racist dude
you thought [ __ ] mario van peebles
was omar epps
and you're like it's not we just i'm a
white guy
give me some leeway you know
uh but he
but yeah dude he looked like tom cruise
i don't remember why i was making that
racist joke but whatever
maybe maybe it's because i'm [ __ ]
racist
can we just agree that everybody's a
little bit racist and it's not even in a
[ __ ]
like we love you can love more than you
actually
do you know what i mean like you ever
[ __ ] like
like white people are like like what
like okay if okay
all right let me just break this down
what race eats like this
nobody would say anything but a white
guy
is that racist if you're watching this
podcast i say
what race eats like this
how many what percentage of you you
think thought white guy
that's not racist or we're all a little
bit racist
it doesn't mean you can't love white
people too yeah we eat like that
some of us definitely no mexicans and
black people eat like that
but when white people do it's kind of
gross
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man
it's a good time it's a good time it is
what it is my baby it
is what it is we have a good time though
we do we have a good time
i get home from therapy just
rip roaring better than i was and
i walk up the stairs and kristen is with
our friend and i'm like
hello they're not in the rooms that we
always hang out in
and i hear
and i'm like they're upstairs
i hope they're not in the bedroom
because then we're going to have the
[ __ ] i don't like hanging out in the
bedroom
with anybody but the person i sleep in
the bed with you know what i mean
like you ever have someone else in your
bedroom that
you ever like have a buddy come over and
you're showing them your house or your
apartment and you're like
how quick is the and this is the bedroom
so we can let's go you want
some turkey meat or let's go to the
kitchen it's just weird
if you're in a bedroom alone with
somebody that you don't sleep in the bed
with
um
yeah god that's so true i don't even
know if i ever thought but like it's
like and even if you're with the person
you sleep with and another person you're
like
like my opener would always come and and
hang and like before we left he would be
there
because like kristen would bill still be
asleep and he'd be like are we bringing
the or will you bring it and i'm just
like bro you keep making the bedroom
dirty dude do you walk in here where
have you been
already today and he's like it's 5 30
a.m we got to get to the airport
i haven't been anywhere anyway um
so they're like hey we're up here and
they're in the the guest bedroom
and i walk in and they're setting up the
closet all nice
you know doing the [ __ ] that kristen
loves doing just she loves
well she loves decorating but she
organizing isn't as
hot on her list as decorating but
organizing
she's learned to do it and learned to
like it much like me going to the beach
so um she they're doing that and i hear
just music i hear music
where it's like they it's like the kind
of music that you
hear that's that
where you're like how dare they
make this arrangement
and just have it blaring because you
could tell it's coming from
outside it's not i mean we were inside
but it was like coming from whatever
they were watching it was like
an outside or it was like a
a [ __ ] old eric clapton live at
madison square
garden and and i'm just like but the
arrangement was how dare they
no words just violins and gongs and i'm
just like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
is going on in that guest room and i
walk in and they're
hanging they're doing the closet all
nice
and i say what
because it's funny because family guy or
the purge isn't on so what
i look left and i see sure enough
outside
so many people it looks like they're at
the goddamn rose bowl
people dancing and gonging
and tapestries and i'm just
hey bud remember what happened at the
beach baby
not knock i got that little matthew
mcconaughey voice in my head
not not but remember the beat she
thought it was gonna be terrible
what'd you say it was oh no come on
what'd you say it was i don't wanna i
don't
who cares i care more importantly you
care
what was it
it was wonderful it's wonderful wasn't
it yeah i don't
why are you in my head matthew
mcconaughey you made me
so now i got to deal with matthew
economy in my [ __ ] head i'm watching
outside and tapestries are flipping all
around and they've got like purple and
red lights and [ __ ] and i'm
and i say what is this and they
say the opening
ceremony of the 2008
olympics
and i say
well i don't want to be in this room
because you're watching
the opening ceremony of the 2008
olympics
and you're organizing
and our friend says i'll just let's make
a spot for you
here and i'm like whoa whoa whoa don't
make me feel bad about saying no
let me just moonwalk on out of here dude
i won't even turn around
i'll just roger rabbit on all the way
downstairs just
boys to men what's going on
a little little doing a little east
coast sun
[Music]
while i'm watching the purge it's all
overdue but
now still gets garden everybody boys i'm
in
jbc bbd the east coast family
just watching speaking of family family
guy
never skip the beat nah well i'm ooh not
chopped everybody was jet lagged then
plenty of band and all the philly steaks
were getting 10
[Music]
oh i'm good at singing dude
and we started to grow up and here we
are
there whatever's better still he says
fish tank somewhere in there
and so um anyway dude
i go i'm gonna [ __ ] roger rabbit
right on out of here dude
i'm going to do the charleston right the
[ __ ] on out of here i'm going to hip
hippity hoppit right on downstairs and
watch the purge if you don't mind me
thank you milady thank you friend keep
on organizing and watch as many as 2008
olympics as you'd like
but i don't want to [ __ ] watch tv
alone so i'm like come on guys let's go
down
and they're [ __ ] they're loving it
dude they cried i found out afterwards
they cried while they watched the 2008
olympics and they're like we're getting
into the spirit because the olympics are
coming again i'm like
it's not a [ __ ] sequel
it's not like you watch the [ __ ]
matrix 3 and you're like wait
what happened to the this is revolutions
there's probably one just called matrix
right yeah and reloaded
oh this is the third one it's not it's
not it's a [ __ ] olympics
japan's gonna play america and [ __ ]
russia's gonna play
another country scandinavia you know i
mean i don't know what [ __ ]
so i'm like let's not and and she was
like you know what you come in here with
this with your energy
and you just got back from therapy and
why can't you just like relax and have a
good time and i'm like i went to the
beach
it's wonderful it was wasn't it shut up
matthew mcconaughey
and uh and so
she's like just watch just you know
can you you know what let's do a deal
and i'm just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] she wants to do a
deal you know what that means i'm gonna
be more
pissed
look man maybe she wants a deal this
deal could be right up your alley
all right [ __ ] listen dude only
because you're
matthew mcconaughey and i really liked
you and sahara
i thought you for good in contact
just i'm listening
what's the deal she says
sit watch it for two minutes i'm gonna
time it
don't say anything for two minutes just
watch
and just try and relax
and have a good time if you can
and i'm like i don't know if i can do
that
that you did at the beach didn't you
yeah
you're right you make a good [ __ ]
point guy from sahara
you make a good point guy from that
movie that's not as good as the truman
show but was a ripoff of the truman show
ed tv yeah
i know
so here i'm now sitting she goes
and i'll say [ __ ] for two [ __ ]
minutes i watch these tapestries flying
everywhere
i watch these people running around gong
and some guys painting over something
already painted like he was doing it
like i'm [ __ ]
41 i know he's not doing it even back
then i was 28.
i didn't knew that who's this for kids
oh pink did he get a big ass paintbrush
i got to admit though his legs were
[ __ ] real he had some some thighs
dude
because he would dip real low down and
[ __ ] pain over the calligraphy
and i'm just like all right dude but he
already did it and he's just going over
retrace
who's this for who watches this
and she says two minutes what
and she looks at her texts and she had
one from me why are you making me do
this
don't hate the player hate the game
that's how we do it dude you didn't say
nothing about
texting dude
[Music]
be more memorable man we're on our be
more memorable [ __ ] dude
yo dude yo
yo dude you boys got severe
problems
yeah dude that [ __ ] was a win and then i
watched [ __ ]
four episodes of the purge
we have a good time dude we have a good
time we laughed a lot
they cried we laughed they cried
we laughed they cried it was the opening
ceremony of the 2008 olympics
the kind of thing on youtube that should
never get more views as the world turns
because it already happened
and who cares about it alas
she was one more of you her and her
friend
that's not true i watched it shut the
[ __ ] goddamn
ass you're done we don't need you
anymore
shoot out of the side of my ear please
um
i see ivan writing something down i i
can't wait to see that graphic
there's no way that gets done
[Laughter]
um all right so uh
yeah man i guess there's one more thing
here
there's actually a few more things since
we're talking about movies and [ __ ] and
things you're entertained by
this was crazy to me i see this epi this
uh
criticism variety on
variety magazine john m two
responds to criticism over treatment of
south asian characters in
crazy rich asians
uh this is an article on variety written
by haley bosselman
i don't i never saw this movie so but
this article
made me be like what the [ __ ] is going
on
rich asians director john m chu sees his
error in casting brown actors in
subservient roles
while promoting his new film film in the
heights chu
told insider that he should have made
the south asian uh
characters in crazy rich asians more
human
and that he totally gets the criticism
the 2018 rom-com hit centers on the
relationship between chinese-american
professor rachel chu
constance wu and history professor nick
young whatever
yeah he takes her home to singapore
that's the plot of the movie you
probably saw it
um
here's my whole thing man
this is how crazy it is with woke [ __ ]
here's here's what i do if i'm john m
chu i know he's got to be political
cause he's in hollywood
but
sometime and i don't know i haven't seen
this movie i don't know this guy's work
he's probably talented
this movie is probably good and it's
probably fine what he did i have no
[ __ ] idea
people are woke i get it what about
how you can just be a bad writer
what about that it doesn't have to be
racist
you can just be a bad writer
oh sorry i didn't make the characters
more believable
you're just bad you're not racist
the error was
you have less talent than you should now
i'm not saying this guy is not talented
i've never seen his stuff i don't know
i'm responding to the article
and the criticism that they're giving to
him guy looks nice enough to me
but dude oh [ __ ] i want to be in this
situation so badly
like where where it's like well chris
why didn't you you made it
you put a brown person in the
subservient role
and i'm just like for [ __ ] sake dude
he worked in a bodega
if you think that i should have made him
white okay fine but [ __ ] i'm bad then
i'm a bad writer
i [ __ ] up yeah but he talked with
this and he said this and that's not how
they that that's not how they actually
all right then i'm bad then then i'm a
bad writer
i'm bad at writing that scene oops
what about oopsie daisy what about that
no you didn't portray
what i think they are the [ __ ]
what about it's just bad remember when
[ __ ] was just bad
it was better when [ __ ] was just bad it
was
better there didn't need to be reasons
for it bro i would watch
[ __ ] eric roberts movies
i would watch bad [ __ ] and it was
better because [ __ ]
you know yeah you
portrayed these margins you marginalized
people with it i'm just bad i'm bad at
it
i tried writing they're not all gonna be
[ __ ] bangers
by the way that was a banger that movie
made 14 trillion dollars or some [ __ ]
that was a banger gone are the days
we're [ __ ] uh
what's his name [ __ ] uh harrison ford
or even jet li
later on gone are the days everybody's
gotta hate
now there's a [ __ ] jetly movie that
comes out people are like it's not
actually real martial arts you wanna
talk about the oh shut up guy
remember the bangers i want to make a
movie called remember the bangers
with [ __ ] gene hackman i know he's
retired and denzel washington dude
they don't make [ __ ] bangers anymore
dude and sometimes they do but
a [ __ ] audience makes them not
bangers like this [ __ ] could have been a
banger
this karen movie
we're watching it it's a trailer a film
by coke daniels a long way from east
point great name already
baby you just got to give it a chance so
many movie trailers
have the [ __ ] that's already
how you know the movie's bad because
it's like it's making you feel like oh
we gotta
uh we gotta get going like dude don't
make the [ __ ]
do it with music at least you know
like when you're in a in a [ __ ]
at the end of the movie and [ __ ] when
everyone was like
and you're like are they gonna get out
of the [ __ ] submarine or not the air
is closing in on them
for [ __ ] sake yeah
that's unfair and we live a life of
fairness
the piano
the one note piano dude
like it's eyes wide shut dude like it's
[ __ ] creepy
bro i want to make a [ __ ] movie
that's creepy and
only have music by the wall flowers in
it
just [ __ ] people getting stabbed to
one headlight
just [ __ ] one headline
[Music]
down around a middle phone
railway
just people spitting up their esophagus
one headlight dude stop with the creepy
[ __ ]
piano and the and the [ __ ] evil
demonic kid in the movie and
i want it
brown
well some guy's wearing another guy's
face
now now it's little falls in the
pronounced day
whatever the [ __ ] little exfoliate
bell
[Music]
just wearing someone else's face we can
put together there
in the middle a [ __ ] on his head make
some freezing drizzle
[Laughter]
some guy hanging
listen to all these missing days
[Laughter]
dude
that's the movie i want to make [ __ ]
give me all the money to make this
[ __ ] dude
i will make it and it will kill and deep
down
even if you're listening to this as a
hater
you know i'm right dude i'll make that
[ __ ]
sing dude i'll make that page come to
life bro
that [ __ ] will sing man i'll have
zero good actors in it and that [ __ ]
will hit
high notes
tell me about your new neighbors they're
black
okay i'm interested
do you mind keeping it down if you don't
comply i'll tell the manager
subtle racism somebody's taking home
security serious
hi i am karen drexler i'm your neighbor
you need to be taking your trash cans
off the curb right when the trash is
a little less subtle a little less
subtle now let me tell you something
right now
this lady who's playing karen
is a great actress and uh
her name is taryn
something and she's great
and she looks like she's great in it and
i'm not [ __ ] that's no sarcasm dude
and everyone in the comments the youtube
thing is like this looks [ __ ]
are you kidding me no i will not stand
for it
i will not stand for any hate in this
comment
in this comment section talk about how
silly
this movie experience might be
i will not tolerate it because it could
be a banger
it could be bad in the right way the
only thing
anyone should be talking about is how
this movie
looks the aesthetic of it it looks
like garbage porn okay now i don't
i didn't understand why until i saw bet
and then i realized okay well it's b-e-t
productions
with this movie that's going to be
coming out
and tyler perry runs that ever since
tyler perry movies
[ __ ] looked a lot worse you know because
he just makes movies
for like a nickel in three cents
and so yeah she's nice
wait a minute we have a white entitled
neighbor
named karen hit it head on
i like it i like it because they're not
hiding from it they're
understanding how ridiculous this script
is congratulations karen movie
good job why does it look
like a porn shoot erin
okay enjoy yourself there she is slaving
away in the kitchen
okay all right she's a good actress
can't say you look there she is slaving
away in the kitchen
can't say that so karen's racist
obviously
i've come across some very suspecting
teenagers always
hurry up please it's very aggressive yep
i left my wallet
with my id at home leave a saloon we
didn't do anything
how the heck did you end up moving to
this neighborhood
so racist we have criminals you take
care of him and i
will take care of her would you mind
stepping out of the car
my office has uncovered some disturbing
information
imagine if all of a sudden liam neeson
shows up
just like they don't want you here
because you're black but i want you here
because you're black
born headlight just cutting up karen
wearing her face
i'm wearing karen's face
i am karen
[Laughter]
come on live a little russian basement
never
they have to stop killing i will kill
we her a search warrant well i'm black
i know she doesn't like you either
kids always speak the truth like that
right i want to sell the house
kids always speak the truth dude kids
will just be like who's the fat guy
when you're at like some [ __ ] little
boutique with you oh
okay okay all right
he means p-h-a-t
i hope so as he runs out with his
mcdonald's
you can't call people fat
you can't tell me huh we are living next
door too i mean she has a [ __ ]
confederate flag soap dispenser uh in
this movie really laying and
laying it on thick karen movie a racist
you went in her house you wouldn't want
your wife to know our little secret
really
i was not staying
you people are very angry
shut your mouth boy
the cops are racist too in it bad things
happen to people that don't comply
[Music]
dude imagine this is exactly what i'm
talking about with the [ __ ] other guy
in the last article it's like imagine if
there's white people that are saying
that this is racist like dude
it's just [ __ ] art who gives a [ __ ]
i don't care either way people are like
whoa
okay how would it be if i made a movie
about dude there are movies about
that and other people complain about
those don't be that [ __ ]
who cares is divisive i don't care dude
don't watch it we're screaming to the
vacuum
look at this hopefully this dislike
ratio will get more numbers than this
movie's audience
just white people just i i'm not woke
dude and i'm not
liberal and i'm not conservative you
know
look at this songbird i'm the most
tone-deaf movie ever
karen hold my confederate soap dispenser
what's songbird that's another movie
song song songbird was that
tone deaf they're all tone deaf they're
movies dude
if they're not tone deaf they're a
[ __ ] movie like nomad land where some
girls just hanging around a barbecue for
two and a half hours
you know what i mean i was [ __ ] on a
plane with francis mcdormand once and i
sat with her
and that that's that was as boring as
the movie nomad land
you know you were so
yeah dude make this movie and then also
make another
racist movie make them all racist dude
i want every character to be [ __ ]
one-dimensional
i want white guys out there just like uh
hey what's going on
can't see without my glasses pens coming
out of his shirt
and then i want a [ __ ] black guy
that's like what's up dog
damn and then i wanted an asian to crash
into both of them
that's the movie i want and then i want
a guy with down syndrome come out and be
like what happened
i want it all dude i don't give a [ __ ]
it's like just
everyone's so goddamn sensitive man and
then when people don't like the movie
i go oops i'm bad
i'm a bad writer sorry you didn't like
it dude
liam neeson wouldn't do my [ __ ] one
i had to make karen
more power to you always okay i can't
believe what i'm [ __ ] saying dude
whatever dude i mean it
goes nuts talking about carrot
crystallia at a racist even though it's
a comedy podcast
absolutely racist slams blacks asians
and whites
oh all of them in the office oh
[Music]
the guy with this [ __ ] coffee mug i'm
sorry little kids
so that's it uh for the episode on
youtube if you would like to catch the
rest of the
episode the uncut version of this
episode go on over to our patreon
and become a member and support the show
patreon.com
crystalia and it would also be awesome
um
and uh we've got a swell of support over
there but also
we need you and if not it's all good
enjoy us on youtube thank you very much
you guys
have a good one
[Music]
congratulations
hey guys welcome to